a story in five words
story in five words Disney tells guests
to behave
all right Drew I guess that the happiest
place on Earth not so happy dude if you
think that's the happiest place on earth
I feel so sorry for you if you've never
been happier than when you're at
Disneyland actually that might be why
this people are punching each other
because they set the bar so high they're
like you're never going to be happier
than you are when you're right here and
then you're you're not that happy so you
just start punching people the other
thing is without exceptions halfway
through the day your kids become
overstimulated start really becoming a
behavioral problem and so pieces people
are very uptight I found it odd that a
lot of this happened in Toontown and I
wonder I just wonder if the violence of
like a Roger Rabbit is encouraging
hitting people with mallets and things I
wonder if that encourages that behavior
that's an interesting point because
Disney World Adam said be the magic you
want to see in the world first of all
okay but
also what if the magic you want to see
is more fights
well it does I have been in a good mood
at Disneyland and then you find out that
they went 17 for a churro and start
rolling up your sleeves and wanting to
throw down with anybody around you
uh so they didn't gouge for the food
that might you know that might help a
little bit but it is kind of interesting
that we're living in a time where people
are getting into fist fights on
commercial airline flights and
Disneyland like when I was growing up if
you said where do you fight it'd be bars
and bowling out if somebody said how
about a Pan Am flight in the happiest
place on Earth you'd go Zero fighting
there it's for bars and pool halls and
bowling alleys now there's almost no
fighting in bars but yeah driving on
commercial flights in Disneyland has
gone up seven thousand percent that's
true yeah Cheryl what do you think uh
this is why Disney's stock is down so
substantially this really the theme
parks is like the biggest Revenue
generator for for Disney overall so
obviously but I can't believe the
language these could we all just get
along would you like a lollipop after
your fist fight you know we're going to
throw you out if you get into a fist
fight I mean shocker you know to no one
so yeah I mean obviously they've got a
lot of problems at Disney this is I
think one of the smaller ones uh but you
know what can I say people getting into
fights at Peter Pan is this what we've
you know come down to that's kind of sad
I think they're mad about the admission
price honestly I think I think Adam's
right yeah are you sure you can't you
can't afford Disneyland I mean our world
honestly and I might not be most people
but hearing that it's
hearing that it's become some sort of a
lawless hellscape makes me want to go
yeah I like this
as long as they're punching Disney
adults yes you know I'm saying the 35
year old with the Mickey Mouse hat that
don't quite fit right
away yeah swing away like you're right
on their honeymoon yeah at Disneyland
you make me sick
[Laughter]
I mean
picture this you got the kids yeah it's
hot yeah you and the wife it's like day
it's like day four yeah and you're
walking and some jackass takes a knee
and proposes
and you're like and then you get the
look like you never did that for me
it wasn't until I had the second one
that you married me you got to deal with
that and the guy's like hey can you take
our picture
[Laughter]
there's a silver line in here like
you're hurting for money Disney you're
hurting for money right Disney fights
world star you know what I'm saying yeah
get the gloves set up a little teacups
around there
Donald Duck perfect rep he goes off by
he used to cuss on cartoons when we were
a kid slow it down you see it now he got
mad he always tried to fight you know
bring him in there use a little
chipmunks in the corner let's make some
money goofy referee let's do this yeah
let's be fair it's a breakdown in our
civility we are no it's not it's not
okay if you think about it I went to
Disney on your hunt you like you just
get married where do you want to go a
Park full of kids
from a guy who likes to swing it out
they fight in Disney because they can't
fight it to corolla's point they don't
fight in bars anymore in alleys because
no one's there to break it up so they
Let's Get It On in Disney because five
thousand happening people will be like
please stop don't do it we're at the bar
to be like I got 20 on the tall guy yeah
I'm I'm with you yeah I'm with you on
this one I think we're on to something
watching people slap by Disney's not
with something I'm into I mean the good
news is they're all morbidly obese now
so they're like
I'm this close yeah getting out of this
scooter and opening a can of whoop ass
stop to eat something you got to eat
something you didn't hire Seventeen
dollars
look at how uncomfortable that all he
wants to do is for everyone to be happy
look at him I would love to see him go
swing on somebody at Disneyland that
would make my career it would you
imagine the guy I got punched by Dr Drew
I'd be like you so must have deserved it
yeah I would love to too all right don't
go away hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else